[Musique]
joe déjà une surprise le fou pour l'un
d'entre vous et gilles reste avec nous
bien sûr parce que ce soir c'est aussi
votre soirée pour le moment on a une
vidéo est un garçon qui s'appelle david
regarde on va pas déjà je suis fan de
toi je suis autant fan de toi que ma
femme mes fans d'avenir donc voilà on se
marie bientôt et si tu peux lui faire un
cadeau franchement je t'en serai
éternellement reconnaissant ça sera un
truc de ouf je t'embrasse baba et
surtout reste toi même gros bisous
ona est david alors david ta femme parce
que va-t-on c'est ta femme elle est fan
dhamir et il y en a une qui a voulu te
faire une très très grosse surprise
regardez ça valérie bénaïm elle s'invite
dans tous les mariages gratuit regardez
c'est la grande régalade de baba lantin
ça c'est très très fort c'est parti tut
raisonnée c'est parce que je suis donc
assez partir et à la recherche à
valentin le groupe comptait sur le star
qui va faire une énorme surprise
un jeune couple qui se marie la géci
contente de douar tu appelles toi je
t'écoute ce soir tu vas être un homme
extrêmement attendu tu vois ce très très
joli couple l'armée
david jaunards qui se marie ce soir
félicitations à la haie et l'or elle est
complètement dingue de toi mais frei est
évident si gênant est d'avis que nous a
missionné et vos petits viennent chanter
comme non partant alors il ya scénario
de dingue tu vas être complètement
transformer complètement gris mais tu es
prêt à la mer j'ai presque fini
salut les amis valentin j'espère que tu
seras fier allez c'est parti
[Musique]
franchement regarde moi ils
méconnaissent à gela sûrement vers
centre et moi je dis moi tu as ton coeur
qui bat
j'ai un bon exemple c'est moi qui vais
me marrer ça y est on est arrivé à y
aller tous
[Musique]
oh
ça y est vous premier
[Musique]
ça y est c'est le moment tu es prêt je
force
[Musique]
pareil faire
alors alors regardez dans les tons coeur
qui battait à 1000 non pas deux mais tu
es parti trop vite tu m'aimes pas eu
dans une boîte non mais je vous laisse
penser je voulais aller deuxième passage
j'ai 33 ans je joue j'ai le coeur qui
bat fort
[Musique]
là je suis sûr qu'elle va vue elle a
rien grillé elle a regardé le vert
indienne et je crois pas
elle a dit je bois pas tout ce que j'ai
pu entendre merci hein quand vous êtes à
côté de moi je suis réconforté chez le
coeur à trois milles à l'heure
[Musique]
j'ai vu pourquoi quelqu'un ville laisse
un message je te laisse regarder ces
cadeaux mon âme au tigre est que david
et shona ce mardi c'est la soirée de
l'année
salut shauna ma belle c'est david ton
mari qui m'a contacté pour que je te
fasse une petite surprise
alors malheureusement je ne peux pas
être présent ce soir mais je suis de
tout coeur avec vous et j'espère que
vous kiffez et j'espère que vous vous
amusez parce que c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on se marie je vous souhaite
tout le meilleur du monde une vie
amoureuse parfaite et plein de beaux
enfants vous embrasse très très peur
félicitations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une deuxième surprise pour toi mon amour
j'ai pour toi mon amour je t'aime
[Musique]
g
à
[Musique]
on a crevé à mes envies d'achat
hu
t
à
[Musique]
un point de repère partagé en deux
émission
je dis je
en de goûter à la
j'ai vu tant de ligue arabe
m
non
moi
et
tu as tu
dans mes bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la banquise est là
je sais que ça va être un bandeau grâce
à valérie bénaïm et grâce à venir qui
est formidable un moment qui sera gravée
dans vos têtes
avi asie franchement franchement c'était
le meilleur cadeau de mariage qu'on
aurait pu me faire vraiment merci
beaucoup et merci à valérie oui merci
beaucoup d'allées les personnes pour ce
que tu avais vraiment incroyable
incroyable et ça te gêne pas trop ta
meuf elle kiffe autant donc mec j'ai vu
sur le coup j'étais un peu gêné mais je
me dis ça à venir c'est pas moi qui
prenais la toque j'ai pas de nos
mariages
[Applaudissements]
vers ses marques avec lui et on vous
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
bonheur vous êtes formidables merci des
chiens
merci d'avis
[Applaudissements]